Cyril à toulonné fait face au squat de
sa maison qui louait depuis quelques
années il s'agit pas d'un simple squat
la maison cyril a été saccagé incendie
elle est désormais au-delà de l'insalub
et il est fort probable que la maison
est même servie de points de l'île
aujourd'hui il dort dehors pour se faire
entendre l'histoire de Cyril a fait
froid dans le dos comme toutes les
histoires qu'on a pu vous raconter
dessus mais celle-ci là on a encore
passé un un palier il vient nous la
raconter dans un instant il sera
accompagné de son avocate mettre Lola
Luciani je dis souvent qu'on marche sur
la tête dans ce pays et bah là c'est
l'illustration parfaite regardez Gilles
tiens ça c'est pour toi tu vas pouvoir
parler avec tes amis ce soir
c'est une affaire qui ressemble à tant
d'autres ces derniers temps et qui
bouleverse la vie d'un Français un
nouveau conflit entre propriétaire et
squatteur
Cyril qui a acheté une maison à Toulon
en 2012 vit aujourd'hui un véritable
calvaire depuis que son ancienne
locataire a quitté les lieux et que son
logement se retrouve squatté incendie
assez reprises et fortement dégradée sa
maison ou les déchets s'accumulent
auraient même été un point de deal
l'homme qui a dû s'installer dans une
tente doit aujourd'hui effectuer
d'importants travaux de réparation de
plusieurs milliers d'euros et est
aujourd'hui au bord du gouffre j'ai
pensé à me flinguer maison squatter
saccagé incendié le cri du cœur d'une
victime de squat ce soir dans TPMP
on va on va avoir le témoignage de Cyril
merci Cyril d'être là dans un instant
juste avant je vous avais dit que le
pape avait été videur
de boîte de nuit voilà merci voilà lors
d'une visite du paroissiens c'est un
père c'est pris au jeu des greniers
quelques lignes de son CV et révéler à
passer pas toujours créer catholique
[Rires]
vous l'avez dit personne ne le savait
ici
Cyril merci Cyril d'être là merci à vous
c'est un truc de fou ton histoire elle
est folle on va je te tutoie parce que
il y a pas de souci ça te dérange pas
merci Maître Lola lucioli d'être avec
nous merci beaucoup on dilutionné
on va vous appeler maître comme ça au
moins vous êtes propriétaire depuis 2006
d'une maison à Toulon dans le quartier
Saint-Jean que vous avez acheté 160000
euros jusqu'ici vous êtes célibataire
vous êtes célibataire vous faites quoi
dans la vie je suis sans emploi
actuellement d'accord donc vous avez un
vesti forcément c'était le projet de
votre vie 160000 euros cette maison et
donc avec un prêt sur 25 ans ah oui on
imagine bien vous remboursez toutes les
queues tout en bon vous remboursez tous
les mois ça commence à être compliqué
bah forcément voilà et donc
vous avez fait un crédit donc sur 25 ans
c'était une maison quoi c'était c'était
quoi c'était une maison voilà c'était la
maison dans laquelle vous serez un
investissement c'est une maison de
famille d'accord et mon oncle et ma
tante la Vendée ils étaient très âgées
ils étaient malades d'accord d'ailleurs
ma tante est décédée le 12 juin de cette
année à 89 ans et elle est partie sans
savoir ce qui se passait et mon oncle à
92 ans il n'est pas au courant de ce qui
se passe ils sont
dans le Maine-et-Loire loin heureusement
et loin de Toulon et on les a protégés
de ça
c'est un véritable drame que vit Cyril
et ça me révolte je vous le dis ça s'y
espère que les choses vont bouger ce
soir après qu'on en est parlé parce que
vous allez écouter cette histoire qui
est juste incroyable
c'était en 2013 donc vous décidez de la
mettre en location pourquoi parce que je
changeais de région pour des raisons
professionnelles d'accord et
voilà j'ai mis des annonces sur
leboncoin d'accord vous avez passé je
suis pas passé par agence ni rien c'est
vrai qu'à l'époque on entendait pas trop
de choses encore comme il se passe en ce
moment
et voilà et ça ça a commencé un peu les
premières commencent à arriver petit à
petit et à partir de
2017-2020 ça a commencé à s'aggraver on
va en parler de ces problèmes dans un
instant c'est vous qui avez choisi vos
locataires donc comment vous avez fait
pour les choisir vous avez beaucoup de
demandes vous habitez dans le quartier
leur propriétaire vendaient
l'appartement d'accord et voilà j'ai
fait un entretien avec eux oui le couple
le monsieur travaillait tu es en CDI
j'avais appelé son employeur d'accord
madame travaille pas mais voilà ils
avaient
des locations logements comme beaucoup
de Français
il me paraissait correct
alors juste le ils sont ils sont combien
ils sont deux un couple et deux enfants
deux enfants au départ deux enfants au
départ deux enfants c'est ça le truc
vous allez voir au départ deux enfants
que vous inspirer confiance
et vous aviez acheté une autre maison
pas du tout j'étais parti j'étais parti
de m'installer en Normandie j'étais en
location d'accord très bien donc grâce à
donc au loyer que vous aviez touché vous
êtes dit je vais payer ma location et au
moins ça me permettre voilà non le prêt
surtout
le prix il est de combien par mois 800
euros pour 800 euros donc ça ça fait mal
tous les mois ça fait mal alors
au bout de quelques temps de nombreux
problèmes commencent à arriver avec donc
c'est c'est locataire
et Madame a eu des gros problèmes drogue
alcool et le couple s'est séparé
d'accord qui est resté dans la maison au
début une savais pas à partir de 2015 et
en fait c'est
entre 2015-2017 monsieur était toujours
dans les parages j'ai su qu'il y avait
eu une tutelle ou une curatelle je
n'étais pas vraiment informé je savais
qu'il y avait quelque chose mais
ça venait que du mari donc j'étais pas
vraiment
courant de ce qui se passait je savais
qu'il y avait quelque chose et à partir
de 2017 en fait l'UDAF du Var m'a
contacté en m'obligeant à refaire un
bail au nom de Madame
puisque c'est elle qui voulait rester le
mari c'était pas marié mais son concubin
partait donc il vous parce qu'il voulait
pas qu'elle ait des soucis de froide à
la CAF donc ils ont dit on va la mettre
mère isolée pour qu'elle ait plus de
prestations et j'apprends en fait il y a
6 enfants d'accord donc et mais c'est
pas fini c'est que à partir donc de 2017
on m'objet à refaire un bail ils n'ont
pas voulu que je la rencontre ou que je
vienne sur place je leur ai dit quand
même que voilà il y a qu'un du soucis
mes voisins se plaignaient les riverains
aussi que moi dès que je pouvais un peu
descendre vu que j'étais en Normandie
c'était pas non plus facile je
constatez un peu voilà que c'était pas
très joyeux sur place et
en fait sous la menace se voila ils
m'ont obligé ils m'ont dit un son pourra
pas vous la faire partir avec tous les
enfants nous on voit pas la reloger on
lui trouvera pas de logement donc soit
vous faites un bail soit on appelle la
CAF en coupe la CAF et on vous paye pas
le complément
l'UDAF du Var un organisme de tutelle et
curatelle
vos voisins vous le disent qu'il y a des
problèmes oui mais ça fait pas encore
pris les proportions que ça a pris à
partir de 2020 et 2021 donc le curateur
qu'on voulait dire indique que les poux
n'est plus là et vous force la main pour
rédiger un nouveau bail ce que vous
venez de nous raconter
il est arrivé quoi votre locataire
l'autre il est pas j'ai jamais revu les
parties donc ils savent sa femme et
toute seule avec les enfants avec les
enfants et en 2020 j'apprends par mes
voisins quand lui retire les enfants
donc pourquoi vous n'avez pas rompu ce
bye à ce moment là
je car étant carrément été paumé je
savais pas j'avais
pas toutes les connaissances même si
j'ai pas toutes les connaissances à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui mais j'étais pas
assez armée juridiquement j'avais pas
les moyens de de
j'étais vraiment perdu j'étais
[Musique]
donc votre logement se dégrade et ce qui
se passe
à partir de 2021 j'apprends par la
tutrice qui a de plus en plus de
désordres que en plus de problèmes elle
me demande de faire intervenir des
artisans mais je lui dis que moi c'est
pas de ma faute et en plus j'en ai pas
les moyens j'apprends donc en 2020 quand
on lui a retiré ses enfants j'ai la
confirmation j'appelle depuis combien de
temps vous le paye pas de loyer vous
avez pas de loyer non alors pendant
entre 2013 2017 il y a eu sur les quatre
ans à peu près la moitié qui a pas été
payé l'IDF du Var c'était engagé à
reprendre le paiement vu qu'elle allait
avoir de
bonnes prestation il y aurait assez pour
aussi un peu combler petit à petit les
impayés par contre c'est vrai que par
exemple je suis honnête ils ont repris
le paiement des loyers ils ont payé les
ordures ménagères chaque année chaque
année j'avais une attestation d'as voilà
là depuis quand le loyer n'est pas payé
depuis deux ans depuis deux ans donc
deux ans de loyer à 800 à combien de
c'est combien par mois bah 800 euros 800
euros pour
que j'étais en maladie j'avais 1200
euros de de
d'Inde des métiers journalières et là
que le chômage 1000 euros voilà on fait
vite le compte bien sûr alors
vous passez de temps en temps de votre
maison ou pas du tout oui surtout à
partir de sur toi à partir de l'été 2020
puisque là après j'étais revenu sur la
région
et surtout à partir de surtout à partir
de 2021 ou là
catastrophique bah oui alors il y avait
qui dans cette maison
dans cette maison il y a eu beaucoup
d'occupations il y a eu beaucoup de gens
qui sont passés honnêtement je peux pas
tout vous dire mais
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on lui a
restitué la garde de ses enfants qui
étaient encore mineur donc sûrement les
quatre derniers en 2021 sauf qu'en fait
en 2020 j'apprends qu'elle est enceinte
dans un septième d'accord et elle a eu
un septième enfant en janvier 2021
oui que je ne connaissais pas que j'ai
rencontré pour la première fois en 2022
l'année dernière d'accord il n'était pas
sur le bail 6 mai 2022 les clés de votre
logement sont rendus par le curateur
c'est ça ils ont pas voulu venir sur
place c'est moi qui ai dû me déplacer
sachant que j'avais fait déjà pas mal de
route
j'ai dû me déplacer sur place les
chercher on m'a reçu derrière une vitre
il m'a rendu des clés qu'en fait ne
servait plus du tout à rien le portail
le portillon dans plus de images dans un
instant juste il y avait un constat
d'huissier qui devait être fait ce
jour-là elles ne sont pas venues
la directrice de l'UDAF ni la tutrice au
curatrice et vous devez quelle somme en
tout ah bah là il y avait à ce moment-là
il y avait on était avec l'arrière et
d'avant là on est à quasi 5 mois déjà
que c'était plus payé
donc presque deux ans et demi là de
loyer d'accord 2 ans et demi loyer ce
qui fait à peu près donc 800 euros ah
non là c'était loué au départ c'était
800 euros et en fait même avec les
augmentations annuelles ils les ont
jamais pris en compte un locataire non
plus pourtant
à 25000 25
si on a si on arrondit même aller pour
aller à 1000 euros puisqu'il y avait
quand même toutes les augmentations en
disant qu'il n'avaient jamais compté 20
euros par an
le plus c'est pas non plus bien alors
depuis vous y êtes retourné vous allez
voir l'état de la maison c'est
catastrophique regardez regardez l'état
de la maison
on a l'impression que c'est un faux
bague mais qu'est-ce que c'est ça
regardez l'état de la maison
incroyable
regardez bien l'état de la maison de
Cyril l'équateur
s
après vous allez voir toutes les photos
là et qu'on les remette ensuite c'est
incroyable tout ça c'est chez vous donc
ça c'est quoi ça ça c'est quoi pas on va
s'arrêter faire il y a plein de choses
qui ont été ramenées même la baignoire
qui n'y est plus c'est une douche qui a
été mis à la place qu'à exploser avec un
énième incendie sûrement au printemps
parce que l'hiver dernier elle était
encore les vitres est encore incroyable
c'était quoi ça c'était la la cuisine la
cuisine on peut voir on va faire on va
faire on va faire le le tout on en
reparle à la chambre c'est incroyable
c'est incroyable non ça c'est le salon
ah c'est le salon après il y a des
chambres qui sont alors c'est sûr que
c'est une maison avec un étagement
sardée
c'était des chambres à l'étage une
chambre sur une mezzanine et deux
chambres dans les combles
c'est une maison qui servait il y a de
toute façon il y avait des clients il y
avait tout trois clims elle était clean
la maison je vous l'avais loué elle
était des années 80
elles ont tenu encore ça va quand vous
avez mal
c'était comme ça ou pas non parce qu'en
fait ça c'est surtout depuis cet hiver
c'est devenu comme ça puisque comme
l'assureur n'a pas réagi rapidement mais
la maison a été squattée mais surtout
j'ai pas été prévenu en septembre
l'année dernière il y a un an qu'elle
était partie que il avait relogé alors
là on voit une échelle il y avait un
escalier avant il parlait
et dans le garage et la le balcon là que
vous voyez là qui permet la mezzanine
devant j'ai joint des photos comment
c'était avant
on a des photos de comment c'était avant
s'il vous plaît en équipe parce qu'on a
envie de voir quand même on arrive voir
le le comparatif et comment ça ils ont
l'escalier ils l'ont pété volontairement
peut-être si oui parce que en fait
l'échelle il la remonte aussi quand il y
a des squatteur il a remonte en haut
parce qu'une fois je pensais en fait
elle était même à moi cette échelle elle
permettait de tailler un bougainvillier
qui était sur une façade extérieure donc
ils ont cassé pour que les gens puissent
pas monter ah c'est ça donc ils ont
enlevé l'échelle ensuite tu dors pas ça
tu vas l'entendre est-ce qu'on peut voir
les photos de l'appartement avant s'il
vous plaît avant bah si elle peut
arriver vite merci
vous avez tenté de chiffrer les travaux
vous voyez il y a des artisans qui sont
venus alors c'est sûr qu'on part au prix
de la maison ou quand je l'ai acheté ça
paraît on est aux alentours de entre 250
quoi plus de 250000 euros de travaux
parce qu'après il y a aussi tout tout
160000 euros il y a 250000 € de travaux
enfin je pense je suis pas du bâtiment
mais je pense déjà aussi les envoyer
toutes les écritures je sais qu'on
devait en venir après mais beaucoup
d'écriture d'après les experts c'est des
montants des puisque en plus il y a des
bars il y a plein de trucs des montants
de ce qui est vendu à l'intérieur en ce
moment des choses pas très
on dit que ça on dit que ça a été ça a
été un lieu deal oui alors en fait comme
vous le savez comme certains personnes
doivent le savoir je me suis installé
ces derniers jours devant mon assureur
sur une avenue assez passante à Toulon
et
beaucoup de gens sont venus voir des
riverains qui habitent à proximité qui
me connaissait pas je remercie beaucoup
donc hier parce que faut savoir que hier
soir encore à 21h30 j'étais installé
avec mes tentes d'accord c'est pour ça
aussi que je suis désolé si je parle un
peu très fatigué mais voilà il y a
beaucoup de sommeil ces dernières nuits
j'ai pas beaucoup parce que si vous nous
rejoignez cette histoire est folle
regardez l'état de sa maison logement
qui a été qui a été exploité c'est un
truc de fou donc là c'était un lieu de
Deal alors là
la mezzanine et l'escalier avant avec la
mezzanine donc là vous aviez ça avant et
maintenant vous avez avec l'échelle et
donc en plus il y a eu une extension de
fait ça fait que regarder il y a en fait
ça tout le dessus du salon alors
qu'avant il y avait un plafond de 5
mètres voilà enfin bon si avec ça parmi
et donc c'est un lieu de dire parce que
la mezzanine c'était une chambre on
pouvait mettre un lit un lit deux places
c'est là où vous dormez quand j'étais
petit en plus alors bon vous avez
demandé à les déloger un moment vous
êtes dit je vais aller les déloger
qu'est-ce qu'on vous a dit les
squatteurs
mon avocat de mettre des dire mais en
fait c'est même pas les squatteurs qui
me dérangent le plus en ce moment parce
que qu'est-ce que je vais faire de la
maison qu'est-ce que je fais de la
maison
si j'ai pire comme on dit des fois bon
c'est ce qu'on a qu'est-ce qu'on va
avoir après
vous allez faire quoi de la maison
alors d'aujourd'hui si
la justice fait pas son boulot si elle
l'UDAF du Var enfin là il y a tellement
de choses à dire mais lui DAF du Var a
manqué leurs engagements parce que
ils se sont jamais présentés aux
expertises une seule fois mais l'expert
n'est même pas venu pour l'assurance de
la cataire ils n'ont jamais déclaré
aucun sinistre il y en a même certaines
il y en a même certaines qui n'étaient
jamais allée sur le lieu de la maison
parce que des fois elle allait au
rendez-vous à la gare ou sinon enfin sur
une commune à côté de Toulon ou lui là
se trouve soit après c'est des trucs
comme on dit les tutrices ou éducatrices
qui se sont enchaînés chaque année donc
là là aujourd'hui donc là vous vous
retrouvez avec cette maison vous avez
payé 160000 euros vous payez encore 800
euros je compte 2031 vous allez payer
800 euros par mois pour cette
inhabitable et dans laquelle vous me
dites il y a 200 50000 euros de travaux
donc c'est quoi la solution aujourd'hui
mettre vous êtes là l'avocat de Cyril
qu'est-ce que vous dites là qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire parce que il y a plein de
téléspectateurs qui nous rejoignent
certainement 21h09 en étant direct et
Cyril c'est une histoire de fou sa
maison était squattée il avait pris des
locataires qui sont restés dans la
maison qui n'ont pas payé leur loyer qui
vous doivent plus de 2 ans de de loyer 4
ans ils ont quitté donc la maison dans
un et ils l'ont mis laissé dans un état
catastrophique qui est irrécupérable
aujourd'hui mettre les assurances elles
sont quoi là dessus
alors pour être tout à fait transparente
avec vous moi je j'ai été saisi très
récemment par Cyril donc les assurances
à ce stade et à mon sens et de ce qui
m'a de ce qui m'en a expliqué n'ont pas
fait grand chose effectivement les
experts sont venus sur place pour pour
constater les les désordres
parce que là tous les spectateurs qui
nous regardent ils nous disent comment
il va récupérer son argent est-ce qu'il
est possible que des assurances
rembourse tout ça le problème c'est que
on a on a on a deux assurances qui qui
doivent intervenir on a l'assurance du
de la locataire et l'assurance de Syrie
la question qui se pose c'est de savoir
si vraiment l'assurance du locataire
peut être engagée à mon sens c'est
compliqué dans la mesure où si les
dégradations ont été commises
volontairement par elle
il est impossible de il est impossible
pour l'assurance de prendre en charge
s'agissant de l'assurance habitation de
Cyril l'assurance de Cyril dont on parle
là est-ce que c'est ça et devant
laquelle il a posé sa tente pas de pas
de réaction de leur part d'ailleurs il a
il a installé sa tente lundi
la compagnie d'assurance c'était pas la
première fois puisque au mois de mai je
me suis même installé devant le siège
mais alors la tente donc voilà vous êtes
devant la tente parce qu'ils font rien
ils font rien
de payer tous les mois l'assurance
chaque jour je suis à jour normalement
vous pouvez les appeler j'ai rien à
cacher
au mois de mai je me suis installé donc
devant le siège à Levallois-Perret pas
loin de chez vous bien sûr en tout cas
de vos studios et on est même pas venu
me voir on m'a même pas demandé ce que
je voulais ils sont même pas sorti me
voir on va pas demander on m'a pas
proposé de rendez-vous
j'ai été délogé puisqu'en fait j'ai
appelé et j'assume je mets toutes les
responsabilités parce qu'il y a une
audience au mois de novembre ils ont
porté plainte contre moi puisque j'en
avais tellement marre il dit il faut
quoi il faut que je rentre et que avec
une arme ou je flingue tout le monde
pour être entendu donc j'ai été
délogé par les policiers je tiens à dire
que les policiers de levain Perret
avaient été toujours et jusqu'au bout de
très correct malheureusement ce jour-là
pendant la garde à vue j'étais blessé
avec des menottes à ma main gauche
j'étais vue par un par un médecin
légiste un jour dit été donc ça a été
considéré comme des violences policières
bon je leur en veux pas mais ce qu'il y
a c'est quoi là GMF ne me répond pas me
raccroche au nez si j'en arrive à à Spa
aujourd'hui c'est que on me répond pas
on me raccroche on ricane ou sinon il
laisse le combiner la GMF 23 milliards
de chiffre d'affaires par an un siège
énorme à Levallois-Perret
je vous en remercie vous m'avez appelé
puisque ça fait quand même plusieurs
mois qu'on était en contact depuis le
mois de mars Au mois de mars c'est moi
qui refusait puisque je me sentais pas
et je pensais que j'allais même pas
tenir sur votre plateau nous si on
voulait vous voir aujourd'hui c'est
parce que ça ça nous révolte ça c'est
vraiment un truc qui me révolte moi
aimer les camarades à part Gilles Verdez
et c'est vrai que on veut que les choses
avancent donc là l'assurance il faut
qu'il bouge très vite si vous saviez
toujours payé votre assurance ils
étaient bien contents de prendre
l'argent quand
[Musique]
je suis chez eux que toujours tout payé
moi là ils sont sérieux d'habitude donc
peut-être vous n'êtes pas tombé sur les
bonnes personnes et peut-être les bonnes
personnes de GMF voilà pour les citer
soit peut-être ils vont les bonnes
personnes vont vous voir ce soir et
peut-être vont agir peut-être vous
n'êtes pas tomber sur les bonnes
personnes et peut-être qu'il y a souvent
aussi des personnes qui ont dit ça c'est
un dossier épineux je préfère pas m'en
occuper donc là peut-être qu'il va y
avoir des responsables qui vont prendre
le dossier
pas le corps et c'est peut-être très
bien que vous soyez venus ce soir pour
que ça fasse bouger les choses parce que
c'est une maison sérieuse voilà je suis
sûr et certain que les patrons de la GMF
sont pas au courant de ce qui se passe
ils sont descendus
me rencontrer
cet hiver je m'étais aussi installé dans
une autre agence à en amont mais ils
m'ont promis des choses qu'ils ont
jamais tenu et moi à la base c'est mon
assurance je voulais qu'elle m'aide et
aussi j'avais aussi une protection
juridique ils ont résilié cet été mais
comme le
sinistre est déjà ouvert ils peuvent pas
ils sont obligés de le prendre ils
avaient mandaté un cabinet d'avocat je
leur ai fait confiance parce que j'avais
pas de cabinet d'avocat d'accord et donc
c'est pas assez de mai 2022 à 23 on
espère que ça va bouger maintenant et
vraiment on va tout faire pour que ça
bouge on vous donnera des nouvelles de
Cyril et